how often are we polishing the hood  instead of looking into the engine it's  well understood that at least half  of what presents to all physical health  doctors arises  from a mental health condition that's a  lot of morbidity mortality cost right  that's coming from that so can we look  and say well what is that that's at the  heart of it and because so much of the  time it is trauma right that is why that  person is not taking care of themselves  right and now oh guess what they're 40  pounds overweight now they have diabetes  and they have high blood pressure right  and we want to throw this medicine that  medicine instead of saying like why  right where is this coming from can we  help you to diffuse this right can we  help you to take care of yourself when  when we actually look at it that way we  do help people be to be healthier and  ultimately in addition to helping people  be healthier and happier we decrease  costs within the system